[Music]
hey everyone
thank you so much for joining us today
and welcome to our resident evil
showcase
i'm your host brittany bronbacher here
to give you a closer look into what
capcom has coming up for the resident
evil franchise
we'll be kicking things off with some
brand new content and an exclusive first
look at resident evil village gameplay
that you do not
want to miss so without further ado
let's get started
hey think positively all right
we talked about this
i know we hardly talk about anything
else
[Music]
they're coming again
mother miranda i regret to inform you
that ethan winters has
escaped that fool heisenberg
because he is in my castle and has
already proven too much for my daughters
to handle
when i find him
no mother miranda yes
of course i understand the importance of
the ceremony
i won't let you down
can someone please tell me what the hell
is going on here
no the place is full of nothing but
blood and death
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
wow well ethan winters
there you are
who the [ __ ] are you
let's see what you're really made of
ethan winters
that was amazing but i still have so
many questions
like when can i pre-order this thing
perhaps producer pete fabiano has some
answers for us
let's see what he has to say
hey everyone i'm pete fabiano producer
on resident evil village
when we first announced resident evil
village back in june we only mentioned
playstation 5
xbox series x and pc i'm happy to
announce
we've been working hard to bring the
survival horror experience onto current
generation consoles as well
resident evil village will also be
coming to playstation 4
and xbox one day and date with nextgen
the ps4 version can be upgraded for free
to the digital ps5 version
and the xbox one version gives you free
access to the game on xbox series x
through smart delivery it's also my
pleasure to tell you
exactly when you can get your hands on
the game
resident evil village will be available
worldwide
on may 7th 2021 with pre-orders
kicking off today alongside the standard
edition
we have a few other options for the game
first we have the digital deluxe edition
available on all platforms players will
be able to heighten their survival
horror experience
with extra content including in-game
items that call back to resident evil 7
biohazard
there's also a collector's edition for
consoles that includes
all the deluxe edition content as well
as a striking figure of chris
redfield a steelbook case poster
and art book and for those of you who
haven't played the previous entry
we have the resident evil village and
resident evil 7
biohazard bundle this lets you get your
hands on the award-winning re7
while you wait for resident evil village
pre-order any of these additions
and you'll be able to get your hands on
both the mr raccoon weapon accessory
and their survival resource pack which
will offer additional support
during the first few hours of gameplay
finally
digital pre-orders from the playstation
store will receive an exclusive
resident evil village mini soundtrack
all right i've been waiting for this i
know you've been waiting for this
it's time for the world premiere first
look at resident evil village gameplay
alongside this first look we have pete
fabiano back to offer some insights as
well
let's take a look
now we're here to give you an exclusive
first look at resident evil village
gameplay
just like in resident evil 7 biohazard
you'll be taking control
of ethan winters you'll make your way
from the village to the castle
players will need to get in and search
for their kidnapped daughter
as you've noticed by now resident evil
village keeps the first person
perspective
we think it really draws players into
the detailed world we've created
you'll see a lot of those little details
come to life here
the team put a ton of effort into
creating a truly authentic feel
from art design to technology everything
ties in great
and creates some beautiful visuals
now it's time to meet some of the castle
denizens as you'd expect
a warm welcome is not really what's in
store crazy
let's take a look at him wow
well ethan winters you escaped
my little brother's idiot games did you
let's see how special you are
shifting gears a bit we're finally going
to show off some combat
it's not just about shooting guarding
will also be an important part of the
game
each type of enemy has their own
distinct way of fighting so you'll need
to change up your strategy to defeat
them
everyone knows what to do with red
barrels right
some of you will remember a similar
management system in resident evil 4.
this time around we've added crafting
which allows you to create
items such as first aid and ammo
there's also an assortment of weapons to
find and utilize throughout the game
i've been waiting for you mr winters
how do you know my name anyone who is
anyone has heard of the likes of you
the merchant makes a return this time
he's known as
the duke you'll be going to him to buy
and sell weapons
amongst other things
the director wanted to give him a unique
look and you'll often find him in
different situations
each time you encounter him
he's an interesting fella
[Music]
smash away with your trusty knife
there's plenty of items to find in your
trap
wait do you hear that
and we've also got extra objectives
outside of the main ones
of course it goes without saying that
there'll be plenty of puzzles to solve
for players to move forward oh and uh
plenty of surprises to keep you on your
toes
i haven't cut open a man in a while
let me stream slice your jugular and
just watch
well that's one way to end the video
now that we've shown you what's in store
for resident evil village
let's take a look at the exclusive
playstation 5 demo
for this demo players won't be playing
as ethan
but as a character we're referring to as
the maiden
unlike the actual game this experience
doesn't feature combat
or even blocking
we're hoping to have players get a real
feel for the visuals and audio
as they take the maiden on her journey
to find a way out of the castle
and you can download the exclusive demo
on playstation 5
today of course we want many people as
possible to get a chance to play
so we'll have a separate new demo
available on all platforms
ready for sometime this spring
this year marks the 25th anniversary of
the resident evil franchise
with the very first game releasing in
japan back on march 22
1996. since then the series has expanded
well beyond the realm of video games
from toys and board games to cg movies
to live-action hollywood films
resident evil has become a cultural icon
resident evil continues to offer
surprises around every corner so let's
pass it along to producers yoshikonda to
hear more about what you can expect in
2021
earlier this month we started inviting
players to join a close beta test
the test won't happen until later
next week but i want to use this chance
to reveal more details
with the 25th anniversary of resident
evil coming on march 22nd
we are excited to celebrate this
milestone with the fans
last september we shot off a piece of
key art
showcasing some of resident evil's
iconic characters to start the
celebration
now i'm happy to announce what was
behind that
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
our reverse is one of the ways we're
celebrating the 25th anniversary of the
franchise
showcasing so many of the characters
that fans love
it'll be available for free to anyone
who purchases
resident evil village so be sure to
follow the resident evil social channels
for the latest news
and check out the official website for
even more details
on behalf of massive entertainment and
ubisoft congratulations to the resident
evil team on their 25th anniversary
we can't wait to get our hands on our
reverse for the occasion we are bringing
a celebration to our game tom clancy's
the division 2.
for a limited time you will be able to
collect some of the iconic outfits and
items from the original resident evil
trilogy
everyone that logs in during the event
will get leon kennedy's rock and police
department outfit as a warm-up
now let's have a look at some of this
wow a lot's been happening and i hope
you enjoyed watching
but if you missed anything along the way
don't worry keep an eye on the resident
evil social channels and official
website which will be sharing everything
from today's show
as a quick reminder resident evil
village is available for pre-order
starting today
for the playstation 5 playstation 4 xbox
series x
xbox one and steam for pc and don't
forget
playstation 5 owners get a sneak peek
through downloadable content available
worldwide starting today
it has been an absolute honor to
celebrate the amazing resident evil
leading up to its 25th anniversary with
all of you across the globe
i'm your host brittany bronbacher and
thank you so much for watching
until next time
here we are we've seen big tall ladies
we've seen
bug disappearing ladies we've seen a big
beautiful man
selling us things we've seen a lot of
new stuff from this showcase of the
resident evil village
direct the rezzy direct you're watching
game spot
i'm current davina i'm joined with
tamora hussein and jean-luc zeidken
we're going to get into this
very exciting new resi direct that's
been bestowed
upon us and all the thirst traps in it
so
to kick this thing off uh we saw a lot
of game
well we saw a good chunk of gameplay
more so than we've seen in the past
more specifically we've seen some combat
we've seen a village
there's a ton of questions uh tam let's
kick it off to you what do you think
based off of what you've seen and how
they're kind of following a resident
evil 7 with what they did with action
and what they kind of gave us glimpses
of here
in village so i think overall one of the
interesting things is
it's hard to get a good read on what
kind of resident evil this game is it
seems to be a bit of
everything the village part of it is
what we've seen in trailers up until
this point you know the werewolf things
the
the kind of like old shacks weird
decrepit looking people
so that created this like distinctly
resident evil 4
vibe um which is kind of how we've been
thinking about it up until this point is
kind of like a a resident evil 4 through
the lens of resident evil 7.
this time however we got to be inside
the castle a lot more
and it feels a little more like the
older games specifically
resi one um which is you know in the
spencer mansion and it feels a little
more like
you know you're stuck in this location
and you need to get out which is kind of
a bit resident evil 7-ish as well
so i think that it's really interesting
what they're going for i'm excited to
see how it gels together i'm wondering
if it's like
so one of the new stories that was from
a while back was capcom saying that on
the playstation 5 it will have no load
times
which has me thinking like is this is it
this big world where you can go in and
out the castle and different areas
and experience this kind of different
these different tones
and aesthetics and vibes for resident
evil as in
when you please or is it kind of like
we're doing a hard pivot
halfway through the game into you know
salazar's castle or whatever it may be
that kind of thing
um so yeah i'm excited to see it from
that perspective
it's it's kind of i mean there's been a
lot of speculation leading up to this
point
just talking about resident evil 4 with
this game it's called resident evil
village
the other resident evil game that's got
a village in it is resident evil 4.
and then of course there's like the
subtle teaser that we were going to have
a merchant and then we saw images of an
inventory
but this time around we actually saw
that you're going to be managing your
inventory all tetris like
in resident evil 4 which makes my heart
black and warm and fuzzy
the way i think it should be considering
what we're watching anyways
uh but jean luc seeing that again like
kind of seeing the reintroduction of
these elements that were only seen once
really in resident evil 4
how does that make you feel because i'm
very excited
oh yeah i mean i'm stoked for it like
you know the uh
what i liked about resident evil 7 was
how it kind of harkened back to
the older resident evils and brought
back the slower pace and
like they've done that so now that
they're like all right we're gonna
we're gonna creep some four back in
there as well as like okay yeah like
absolutely i'm excited for that and then
even like they're
bringing in crafting which has been a
thing in uh resident evil 3
and stuff like that i i don't mind that
either like that seems like a nice
addition especially if the game is more
open
in the way we think it is like i um the
ability to
kind of like craft and manage uh
resources will become
even more important um but
man like that castle it it looks so good
it looks so much like resident evil 4 in
like
the exact ways i want it to uh without
being
like just a rehash like i you know
it it feels like four but it feels like
its own very unique
take like i'm not too worried that this
game is just going to be
just for or anything it feels like it's
doing its own thing
like one thing um and this goes back to
kind of what you're talking about with
tam
tam with like loading screens and going
in and out of environments and kind of
what that means for the design of the
game itself
now like resident evil 4 is a much
linear game in comparison like there's
some backtracking like enough to kind of
like
mirror its uh the dna that comes with
resident evil games but like
through and through that game is a 20
hour point a to point b
this game one of their big pushes is
putting village in the title it's it's
like
you know the making sure we know as as
players that village
is a character and of itself now
considering all these things i'm
kind of really hoping in some way that
we get
that resident evil 4 aesthetic but just
crystal clear but
if we can dial that back like the gothic
horror
like a tid bit more action into like the
backtracking puzzle kind of environment
uh discovery thing um that's what i
think or at least
that's what i'm hoping for uh like
i don't know if like what do you think
about that if that's a possibility and
if that's something you even want to see
considering what they did so well in
resident evil 7
kind of like branching seven and four
together here
yeah i think the tricky thing is like
the parts of resident evil 7 that i
enjoyed most were in the front to middle
end
when it started to kind of crescendo
into you know getting stuff done and
ethan
kind of had to shoot his way out of most
of his his
problems and the whole ship bit that was
kind of
the part that i enjoyed the least it
took me out of
that it felt like a again like a pivot
away from what it had been that entire
time
i'm hoping that by having this kind of
castle
and village element it's a little more
like even
in terms of it's not going to be like
the end of this is pure action focused
i think the thing that really i
struggled with was up until that point
the action in resident evil 7 was
considered and a little more deliberate
and that's how it kind of looks hair as
well i know that a lot of people i've
seen online are being like oh it doesn't
it
looks very slow and it looks very um it
doesn't look like it's quick
gunplay or anything like that but to me
that's not what resident evil is like
the slow deliberate pick your shots
make sure that every bullet counts um
experience of resident evil's combat
harkens back to the same stuff as you
know the resident evil 1 resident evil 2
gameplay style so i do want some some of
those action moments i just don't want
it to be stuffed together right at the
end because then that means that
they feel the need to make this ending
be really bombastic
in a over-the-top way and i think that's
where seven kind of not lost me but i
felt like
up until this point you were in this
really smart like cerebral
tense game and then you became a action
game right towards the end and i was
like i could do without that
seven yeah seven felt like it was odds
at itself like it established
it was trying to do this thing was going
back to its like to its
its original re roots maybe even you
know in the light way like they had
backtracking and exploration and the
puzzles were
there i'll just say that because i don't
think they were all that complicated
but i think if you can find a balance of
the thing that resident evil's always
done and well as a franchise for me is
survival horror is like is
is pitting you in such a way that you
have just enough
to be able to fight your way through
something while being terrified and it's
that harrowing experience of like
you can look at a hallway filled with
zombies and you can kind of do that
equation in your head like do i have
enough ammunition to deal with this
should i deal with this
but there's always that chance you could
and i think like
obviously there's some other
installments in this franchise that just
did away with that and became a
hollywood action film and that's
fine they're great in their merit or at
least i like them
anyways so if this game could balance
those two things and i think
just seeing from those gameplay clips
like there might be a chance because
like
even when he was going there was a
sniper rifle i think i saw in the
inventory management stuff
um but if you know if you can limit the
ammunition but just give a little enough
firepower and
like enough enemies that create that
tension throughout
i'm here for it i want it now i want to
move on to
the thirst traps of this game because
this game
on all accounts is very thirsty from the
voluptuous tall woman to the mysterious
sunglasses man who apparently
seems to have superpowers something that
the ground is floating and then there's
of course
our big beautiful merchant man
um why when did resident evil get so
thirsty what happened
john luke i didn't break a towel
i was gonna say like i think it's always
been low-key thirsty like this
everyone loves uh different characters
from everyone in in the resident evil
franchise has got like a
they're clearly a model of some sort and
then we've splashed some blood and some
mud on them
and then i think where it really turned
was mr x where people were like
i think and were like why are people
into this giant man who terrorizes you
the entire time
oh it's because he's well dressed and
has a top hat so then they went into
now they've gone not only not only did
did they go into like let's give
a tall vampire lady this incredibly like
like outstanding outfit where she just
looks so put together and he's clearly
evil and is very tall
but they were like let's give her some
crazy daughters and let the
let's see what the internet does with it
and the internet i can confirm is having
an absolute field day
the guy with the glasses i'm not sure
who he is exactly but i have a theory
um the the tall lady mentions her idiot
brother a few times and says ethan
escaped
him i think that might be tall lady's
brother i think they mentioned
in in the actual trailer a couple times
the name heisenberg
which is not the breaking bad character
they meant
he she mentions him as as as a
someone she knows i think the glasses
man is
heisenberg and it's uh tall ladies
younger brother
um he is got some weird like brad
fit pip vibes to me like you know
disheveled brad pitt um
i don't know people can see like van
helsing like
hugh jackman yeah hugh jackman yes
uh yeah and then like
yeah and then and then um obviously uh
the duke is just the duke
you know what i thirst for i thirst for
the confidence he has in himself
and i thirst for how at ease he is with
his situation
and i first for like the relative peace
of mind he seems to have in
just being in that place but not being
too worried about it
i wish i had that kind of self-esteem
you know when i came when it comes to
their straps i think what happened
is that they saw what happened with mr x
that wonderful stone-faced goon
but then they made the game go first
person and then like okay we can't have
our soap opera
uh model cast of resident evil and now
we see that you see the game through the
eyes of ethan winters we have to make
everything else
just as beautiful and thirsty so like
they had to switch that perspective they
had to get that
in there somehow and they did it with
this now i want to move on to the
demo that came out today and i'm trying
to wrap this conversation up because i
don't talk to you guys i want to play
that
but while we're here and while some of
you may be downloading it at home
uh this is this is more like a from the
looks of it similar to the resident evil
7 kind of demo that they released where
it wasn't really a part of the game
uh jean-luc what do you think about that
are you downloading it right now as we
speak
i'm i'm my girlfriend is attempting to
download it right now for me okay good
she can't find it
uh we'll keep searching after they said
they said
a day they said you know they didn't say
immediately they said
i remember uh the e3 where they
announced the resonant 7 demo
and we were like desperately running
around uh trying to find a playstation
to like plug in
and download it um yeah it seems like
they're it's gonna be very similar to
that demo where
it's not uh directly like you're not
playing the same character but it
you're you're put into a slice of the
game
uh environment and kind of left to
explore around
i'm curious if they will update that
that demo the way
the resident evil 7 demo kind of had
like a couple updates and they added
some things
uh i just want to poke around it and
find all the little secrets
uh in it so yeah you bet i'm going to be
checking that out
um yeah the one thing i'm pretty sure
about i'm sorry
i don't know i was just gonna say and
then they said there's another demo
coming later which will be like a more
proper slice of the game so yeah
looking forward to that too uh from the
looks of it from made it and i'm sure
we'll all be able to talk this later
tonight when we get it i think it's cool
that it it looks like they're trying to
uh that you're going to be hiding from
one of the sexy daughters
uh so at least there seems to be some
element
there rather than the uh like the re7
demo where you were just kind of
going along a fairly narrow path like
uh down that one so i'm interested to
see if there's gonna be some
replayability and some funky things like
you said to be able to find some stuff
uh as well and then going off of that we
do have an official demo coming out
uh i think they said spring so the
game's coming out may 7th which is
fantastic that's awesome that's way
sooner than i anticipated
so i have a breaking breaking news story
for resident evil
tall lady is reportedly called lady
dimitrescu ladies step in my throat
yep that is her name lady string me up
and rip out my guts
what did the one daughter say on the
streets
all right well there we go what is it
lady duh
it's like dimitri but escu at the end
dimitriesku
dimitrisku hmm yeah my beautiful lady
yeah there she is so
next thing to talk about is uh is
something that
capcom keeps doing and i give them so
much respect for doing it
and that is reverse the new on
multiplayer resident evil thing they're
doing
that they've done they keep doing
they're doing it and this one looks like
a
like a death match tam what do you take
away from that
um it looks like they keep trying i'm
not really sure
why they keep trying like uh they don't
really support
any of these um multiplayer games long
enough for him to make an impact
like the one that came with resident
evil 3 like is
our people just gonna abandon i mean if
it hasn't already been abandoned
like i just got people gonna move on i
don't i'm not really sure what the
purpose of this is like it's kind of
weird i'm willing to give it a try but
look it looks a bit janky and i
i mean that's that's kind of what it
always is like they put these things out
and
you give it a try and it always feels
like um
capcom's kind of like public test on
trying things out which
i give them a lot of merit to doing that
at least it's something like a
free attachment to resident evil village
as
the other one was to resident evil 3. um
but yeah you know there it is
it's there like it comes free with to
anyone that purchases
um resident evil village so like i'll
i'll give it a shot
but i don't believe for any reason that
it has any staying power because
capcom just seems to you know abandon
their multiplex
just make a proper give it a good honest
try like you know outbreak three
put a good mercenaries with something
like you know just do something like
that instead of being like
we've created this cobbled together
thing that
might work might not and you probably
won't remember it exists in two months
time
honestly it's funny you say that because
i think the resident evil 6 mercenaries
mode is like
the online for that was fantastic i had
a great time with that
this one seems to have a good one yeah
yeah just keep do just
put that out again i'm fine with that we
would all be fine with that
it looks like it has a big old roster of
carries the characters the play and john
luke i need to know
who's your top pick who are you going to
want to storm around
punching your your buddies with uh well
i liked the i i appreciate that they
don't just have like the main characters
like
um they also have like mr x and stuff
they have the sewer monster from from
resident evil 3 the big
tongue boy and i was like can i play the
tofu block
if i could play oh there you go if i
could place the different i'll play the
matcha tofu one
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna main lady
okay you know what if i could play with
jack baker and i specifically have the
unique ability to bust their walls
100 jack baker that's what i'll say yeah
that's good cool
see and that's the thing i think it's
like here we are creating the the capcom
if you're watching this
take it just take it put tall lady in
there have her insult other players from
a distance
make jack baker be able to burst through
walls like they're made of paper
just take it take it also where's barry
i didn't see barry in there
okay no barry all right so
now is kind of like we kind of already
had a little speculation earlier but i
kind of want to go into like uber
speculation mode because we still didn't
see
everything there's just there's i have
quite a lot of questions
and one thing here like we've had
co-stars to other resident evil games
come and go but this one is a bit
different
because there's the we got javier bardem
hugh jackman
uh vampire hunter boy who apparently has
like magical powers of some kind
um and then of course we have the duke
which we've seen in the past
but there's also this whole village of
characters that we didn't see this time
but in previous trailers they've had
their
their time like they've actually they
seem to be integrating this story in
some
way shape or form so let's speculate for
a second
we have a if we have a sandboxy-ish
res neil game what do we think the
likelihood is of
of having branching side quests maybe
even a skill tree
tim take it away i think i think that
might be
adding too much to the resident evil
experience i think they'll do the thing
where you get to know certain characters
within
i think they really need to sell the
idea that
the stuff that happens in that castle
and the people that live in there are
real bad and i think they do that by
letting you play through the village
stuff
and talking to the village people not
the band the people in the village
um and like they you know you be
they they tell you about how awful they
are and the things that they've gone
through
while you know they're the the people
the dimitrescu family live in opulence
within this castle
it could be like this metaphor for like
or like this kind of
allegory for classism and that kind of
stuff who knows but um
i feel like you're gonna spend a good
amount of time getting to know people
or and characters within the the village
first
and work your way up to being able to
get into
the um the castle and rescuing your
daughter you'd figure out where your
daughter is first of all and why
she's been taken and whether that
werewolf
is chris redfield on all i mean they
pretty
they showed that that image of chris
redfield
half wolf man and he's big
bulky bulkier in this than he was at the
end of resident evil 7.
jean-luc let's speculate a bit what do
you what do let me let me ask what do
you
want to see in this game that we haven't
seen yet or just as a
dream thing to have in a resident evil
game
on the spot if we're going by the
structure of
other resident evils you're specifically
for you got your village you're gonna
get your castle so they're gonna have a
third there's probably gonna be a third
act that they're kind of leaving as a
surprise
uh i'm
hoping that will be like a fun a fun
twist
i i i i'm trying to wrap my brain about
what that could even be like i just go
back to other resident evils like oh you
could go to an
island or you could go to a boat like in
seven did but i
i don't want any of that like i want i
want there to be this like
surprise third act after the castle
where it just goes in this like
insane direction that resident evil
always loves to do
to maybe mixed results as you guys kind
of mentioned like
you know seven maybe did fall a little
short compared to the
rest of it uh but i i always like when
they just get like
really out there and and weird with it i
mean you know they
they they could do anything wesker could
come back they could bring back jake
he hasn't shown up in in a resident evil
in a hot minute
i don't think they'll do that but they
could
hope yeah i mean who knows what that
baby is and i'm hoping that baby is the
final boss and to follow in
the formula of all of us and evil games
i hope you get a rocket launcher
to that baby which is ethan's baby so i
don't know if that's going to happen but
either he's going to blow up his baby
you're going to have her
okay look it's a resident evil game
you're going to have a rocket launcher
as the final send off of the game and we
got this baby
that's assumably ethan's baby um what
that baby is what it's what it's doing
chris redfield took it
um maybe he's trying to turn into a
werewolf and how else are you gonna
exterminate
werewolf baby other than a rocket
launcher i don't know and what if ethan
was a vampire
he's surrounded around beautiful vampire
women he who wouldn't subdue
to i might be part of this situation i'd
be like bite me
take me yeah take take take it take the
wrists take the neck anyways
that's the first trap of resident evil
village that's that's taking me down
this rabbit hole
okay so here we are uh
that was great and also how we can't
forget that leon kennedy's in a suit
at the very end uh for the um the
netflix thing which we've
which we've seen already they showed
that already yeah they showed that
they had no real update to it other than
i think
it takes place after resident evil 4 and
leon has a suit
cool yeah well that's the tie into
resident evil 6 we're looking for
that's your chance john luke to get jake
back in there because if anything i hope
this series ends with
uh with where six left off and that and
that crazy blockbuster
of a roller coaster gets to carry on
through a netflix special which is
probably where it best
belongs um okay am i leaving anything
out i think that's it
everything demo is out today release
pre-order yeah it reminds me we need to
wrap this up because
i need to go
and wait patiently to see it so
thanks for joining us folks if you're
still here sticking around all that jazz
make sure to keep sticking around in the
future because we're going to have tons
of resident evil village
content on the way and you should be
sure of it so if you're not already make
sure to like and subscribe to our
youtube channel
follow us on twitter follow me on
twitter at curt underscore and divina
follow tam
at tomorrow it's just listed
tomorrow then we have done luke
what's your thing oh actually
yeah follow those dudes and me if you
want you don't have to you could do
whatever you want
anyways uh oh and before we go a few
things i want to plug
we have we produced two episodes of a
show called remember when about resident
evil so if you're still
feeling the itch while you're here and
while you're waiting for that maiden
demo
make sure to go to our youtube channel
and search for remember when resident
evil we got an episode about the
wonky goofy infamous soundtrack that was
composed by a supposed
deaf composer uh for the second game and
then we have a new one
examining how resident four was supposed
to be a gamecube exclusive and then
wasn't and how that whole thing
unraveled tim is there anything you want
to
put in there um i think that's pretty
much everything we did a series of
gamespot
studios a little while back that was
pre-resident evil 7 where we went to
japan and
it's fun i was watching it the other day
because it's fun to go back and look at
like our our like preview slash
interviews with them knowing
what the game ultimately became so
that's kind of like a fun little thing
to
check out but otherwise yeah that's
pretty much it just play resident evil
find a resident evil game that you like
and play it
it's a good series have fun dude rip i
swear by revelations one and two
john luke plug some stuff uh well
nothing that you can watch right now but
if you stick around
in a day or so we uh we'll probably have
some video uh talking about the maiden
demo
i think we're gonna try and deep dive in
and see if we can uncover some juicy
secrets for it uh that we can
share with all of you sweet all right
again thanks you
all for joining us for being a part of
our thirsty journeys with resident evil
village
till next time see you folks later
goodbye
you